[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday Hank I
feel that something momentous has
happened in my life but a little bit
fuzzy on the details so I think we
should just go to the tape and try to
piece together the events of the last 24
hours
okay that's me and I'm wearing the same
shirt so it was probably yesterday could
have been the day before but probably
yesterday okay it's dark
oh I think I see the outline of a couple
heads I know those people those are my
friends those are my friends
Hank I was out with my friends last
night I wonder if I was having fun last
night
yes fire yeah looks like I was having
fun it's coming back last night was our
going-away party from New York maybe
there's a clue in my pants it's evil
baby Stalin and who's this little guy
it's evil baby Hitler thanks to New York
Times reporter in my high school friend
cam Robertson for those amazing
illustrations Hank I don't know about
you but that makes me want cam to do the
illustrations for the evil baby
orphanage book if and when it exists in
other news I'm officially a homeowner
that's good been scary Hank I don't want
to be like a new mother about the house
and constantly showing you pictures of
it and stuff but here are some pictures
of it look at the kitchen
it's so nice and then you go upstairs
and that's the loft
I like the loft a lot I'm very fond of
it and actually behind the loft there's
the secret room Hank it's like Webster's
house what do you think maybe 18 20
percent of our viewers have ever seen an
episode of Webster here's the finished
basement here's the ghost of the Yeti
here's the master bedroom I think it's a
great house Hank and I hope that you
will come visit us because we have
carved out a bedroom that is just for
you okay by the way you want to know
something really interesting I've
learned while moving I own
a lot of tote bags and like the tote bag
ferry anyway Hank I'm going to give all
these tote bags away in my pants and
I'll see you tomorrow